we begin this morning with what is
expected to be a tense day in the Middle
East and elsewhere around the world at
issue
what will Iran's next move be following
the US airstrikes on Baghdad Airport
that killed Iran's top military
commander general Qasem Soleimani this
morning thousands of people gathered in
Baghdad for the funeral possession
procession of Iran's top General and
Iraqi militant leaders they chanted
America is the Great Satan Iran is
warning there will be harsh retaliation
for the u.s. killing of Soleimani the
Pentagon says he was developing plans to
attack Americans 3000 US troops are
headed for the Middle East
Ian Lee begins our coverage from the
Iraqi capital of Baghdad this morning he
and good morning good morning we are
seeing a tense day here in fact at tens
of thousands of people are marching in
the funeral procession and we're also
hearing that there have been attempts by
some of the protesters to get to the
Green Zone the home of the US Embassy
it's a show of force in mourning the
streets across Iraq packed his sadness
shock and anger with chants of down with
America the bodies of possum soleimani
and a top Iraqi militia commander led
the march through Baghdad even a Rock's
prime minister Adel Abdullah he was seen
among the crowd while in Iran protesters
had tears in their eyes and death to
America on their lips for many there
sulemani was a symbol a folk hero now
enshrined in martyrdom early Thursday
morning
explosions lit up Baghdad's night sky to
Reaper drones fired four Hellfire
missiles destroying Soleimani convoy
leaving it twisted in blood and metal US
officials say his fiery end was
necessary as American lives were at
immediate risk without offering evidence
president Trump says he doesn't want a
war but he may have triggered one
Iranian president Hassan rouhani vowed
revenge while visiting Seoul emani's
family saying America will see the
consequences of their mistakes not only
today but in years to come Marines who
reinforced the u.s. embassy and more
are on their way to the region to
protect against any retribution but it
could come in many forms and places US
troops are scattered across the Middle
East including Syria and Iraq to
countries where soleimani led Iran's
elite cooks force now those operations
fall to his replacement tensions have
dramatically risen this week all
starting with the death of an American
contractor at an Iraqi base the United
States blamed iran-backed Shiite
militias and bombed their bases in Iraq
and Syria supporters of those same
militias then attacked the US Embassy in
Baghdad leaving parts of the compound
scorched and covered in graffiti but
with the death of Soleimani we've
entered the unknown with no one knowing
just how this will end
one of the final casualties of this
airstrike could be the US military
presence in Iraq as Parliament tomorrow
will debate whether to kick American
troops out of the country Michelle 'only
and Baghdad thank you
you